[Musik]
was für ein nachrichtentag in den USA
will Ex-Präsident Donald Trump bei der
Wahl 2024 erneut antreten darauf folgte
sofort der prompte exit von Trump stop
the Ivanka die bislang fest an seiner
Seite stand und von 2017 bis 2021 sogar
seine Beraterin im Weißen Haus war in
Berlin muss die Wahl zum
Abgeordnetenhaus wiederholt werden und
der Anschlag einer Rakete auf nato-boden
hat für einen Moment Schockstarre
ausgelöst aber Mittag kam dann das
Aufladen es war kein russischer Angriff
damit herzlich willkommen bei Villach 8
meine wunderbaren Gäste heute Abend sind
der Berliner CDU-Politiker und
Bundestagsabgeordnete Thomas Heilmann
der nach dem heutigen Gerichtsurteil für
die Hauptstadt sofortige Neuwahlen zum
Abgeordnetenhaus fordert und auch für
den Bundestag das werde ich ihn fragen
FDP Politiker Daniel fest wird uns heute
gegen Mut machen die Regierung werde
alles dafür tun dass trotz Inflation der
Traum vom Eigenheim nicht Platz ich bin
gespannt manche denken schon über
Lebensmittelpreise nach hier geht es
direkt ums Eigenheim wir werden sehen
Börsenexperte und Youtube Star Mario
Lochner rechnet mit Wirtschaftsminister
Robert Habeck ab dem traut er nicht zu
Deutschland durch die tiefe
Wirtschaftskrise zu steuern und endlich
mal wieder ich freue mich sehr zu Gast
bei 8:15
Uhr er wird heute über den zunehmenden
Einfluss des Islams auf unsere
demokratischen Werte sprechen Staat
möchte ich heute mit dem Mann der die
Welt wieder mal beschäftigt es ist
Donald Trump ja sein Comeback
anzukündigen mit 76 Jahren dazu gehört
schubse er hielt heute Hof gestern Hof
und seine Fans waren schwer entzückt
fallen wir doch mal reiten
America's Comeback starts right now I am
tonight
president of the United States
ja er will zurück ins Weiße Haus
Selbstbewusstsein hat der Mann medial
war das Echo jedoch eher verhalten der
New York Post war es lediglich eine
Randnotiz wer hat mit der Überschrift
Mann aus Florida macht Ankündigung
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz sagte am Rande
des G20 Gipfels in Bali ich bin nicht so
beeindruckt also damit Donald Trump
überhaupt noch einmal antreten kann muss
er ja die Vorwahl der Republikaner
gewinnen aber ist der Trump Hype
eventuell schon vorbei oder sehen es nur
die Politiker so Herr Heimann sie sitzen
ja im Deutschen Bundestag und der frage
ich mich natürlich sehen dass alle so
verhalten wie Olaf Scholz die nicht so
beeindruckt sind oder gibt's da auch
echte Trumps also ich habe noch keine
getroffen
ich kann ihn aber sagen ich war
mir Shake und wir haben uns mit den
Republikanern getroffen eigentlich wegen
Klimaschutz aber man sieht auch das
große Thema und republikanische
Abgeordnete
sagten na ja er hätte
bevor Präsident geworden wäre hätte er
Themen der Menschen angesprochen hätte
deswegen auch gewonnen jetzt ginge es
nur noch um ihn selber auch der
Ausschnitt den wir gesehen haben es geht
ja immer darum dass ihm angeblich die
Wahl betrügerisch entzogen werden soll
und er jetzt wieder da Stimme und so
weiter und das würde ihnen so viel
Sympatien Kosten und deswegen hätten die
Republikaner
man kann glaube ich schon sagen die
mitteilungs verloren wir wissen das ja
noch nicht genau wie das im
repräsidentenhaus ausgeht aber das fand
ich schon sehr interessante Analyse und
das war jetzt auch nicht mal so
irgendwie nebenbei gesagt oder das war
ja eine Sitzung bei der wir uns über die
Situation der Mitte rechts Parteien wie
man das so schön im englischen sagt
Center right sagt man da aussieht ich
glaube nicht dass er gewinnt Herr
Lochner sie kennen sich ja gut aus wie
mein Marketing macht auf Youtube auch
sehr
Erfolgs denn überhaupt Donald Trump
geschafft als
Multimillionär der gerne in seinen
goldenen Protz Bauten mit seiner Frau
gepostet hat dafür zu stehen für die
Sorgen und Nöte der Menschen als ja fast
marketing-stück worüber man schreiben
müsste oder ja es ist ein Marketing
Chemie das ist ja Trumps herausragende
Fähigkeit also er hat das ja ja ich
glaube er hat das gut hinbekommen
Hillary so als Feindbild aufzubauen und
ja das war natürlich genial obwohl er
eigentlich ja nicht wirklich für das
stand unbedingt was er versprochen hat
hat man ihm das trotzdem abgenommen ob
es jetzt noch mal funktioniert
würde ich auch bezweifeln ich würde
jetzt nicht viel Geld auf ihn setzen
aber ich kann mich noch sehr gut daran
erinnern vor der aber sie würden auf ihn
setzen also wenn sie jetzt setzen müssen
wäre es für Trump gut dann müsste ich
erstmal den Gegenkandidaten gegen beiden
ja ich glaube das ist relativ fifty
fifty aber ich kann mich noch gut daran
erinnern
aber damals war auch hieß es auch immer
ja in der Partei das schafft er niemals
das heißt es jetzt auch wieder es wird
sicherlich schwierig aber ich kann mich
noch genau daran erinnern das ist auch
der schafft das niemals der schafft
nicht mal aufgestellt zu werden dann ist
er Kandidat geworden und dieses Jahr das
schafft er auch niemals und er hat es
geschafft also unmöglich ist es sicher
nicht aber ich glaube es wird schon
schwierig für ihn na ja nicht die
Europäer entscheiden sondern die
Amerikaner und was wir nicht vergessen
dürfen Trump ist nicht aus eigenem
Leistung Präsident geworden sondern aus
Gegenreaktion auf die linke und auf die
Demokraten und wenn sie so weitermachen
dann hat Trump eine Chance was sich
nicht hoffe aber das ist nicht nur das
was Trump veranstaltet sondern was die
Demokraten im Alltag und wie fremd ihre
Politik gegenüber die Mehrheit der
Amerikaner geworden ist das macht mir
Sorgen na wo wir das Ergebnis jetzt darf
er nicht so spricht also normalerweise
kriegt einen ein amerikanischer
Präsident
abwarten ich sag noch mal das ist nicht
die Europäer die entscheiden auch nicht
unsere Kanzler aber trotzdem glaube ich
dass die Unzufriedenheit unter die
Amerikaner und die wissen nicht wie in
der Inflation auch weitergeht das konnte
auch vor eine Demokratie noch gefährlich
das ist nicht wir entscheiden aber
natürlich haben wir also wir beobachten
ja die Politik und gerade bei so einem
Land ist so relevant ist einmal für die
globale Betrachtung der Probleme wie die
USA schauen natürlich sehr genau hin das
Problem von Trump ist der polarisiert
halt wirklich wie kaum ein anderer
Politiker in der demokratischen Welt und
da gibt es zunehmend meiner Wahrnehmung
nach amerikanische Werte dieses extreme
polarisieren abstößt die einfach
tatsächlich auch wieder Ruhe wollen
Probleme lösen angehen und ja der Traum
der Politiker der wirklich der Menschen
Ruhe geben Probleme lösen die Menschen
das sie nicht auf Polarisierung stehen
das kann man so eigentlich sagen oder
auf ehrliche Worte kann man es auch
nennen
also ehrliche Worte werden
und das ist eher ein Problem der Politik
dass wir zu viel außen aber das sind ja
nicht Polarisierung
Trump ist ja stark geworden weil er
Probleme die tatsächlich da sind
aufgenommen hat sehr polarisierend
gemacht und hat sich überspitzt und hat
noch mal ein obendrauf gesetzt und noch
ein bisschen Verschwörung mit
reingarniert das hat ihn ja stark
gemacht aber die Probleme die Menschen
wollen ja das Probleme gelöst werden ist
es keiner Suhl sicher gerne darin oh
mann wir haben 10 % Inflation bitte lass
das so sondern die wollen die Lösung der
Probleme und das da ist Trump nicht
schreiben die Trump ja von sich
behauptet ist ja er ist ja nie Verlegung
große Sprüche aber eine Sache die er
behauptet ist dass der Ukraine kriegt
nicht mit ihm angefangen hätte es werden
wir am Tisch jetzt nicht debattiert
bekommen ob bestimmt oder nicht stimmt
aber sehen Sie auch irgendeinen Vorteil
den es hätte wenn Donald Trump regieren
würde oh das ist schwer zu sagen also
Donald Trump ist eratisch das macht
natürlich für jetzt die Partner und ich
finde Deutschland muss ich sehr klar als
Partner als Freunde USA begreifen macht
für die Partner natürlich sehr schwierig
und das große Thema wie wie bekommen wir
die Welt irgendwie von der klimakrippe
runter wie schaffen wir den Klimawandel
zu beherrschen das wird ohne die USA
nicht gehen
Ich finde das immer sehr spannend wie
das gesehen wird dass man Trump
kritisiert und dass da viel ja
fragwürdig ist ist klar aber er wurde ja
damals als ja rückständig und die
Globalisierung wird zurückgedreht und
Handelskrieg was die Amerikaner jetzt
nach Trump machen das ist ja noch mal
eine Stufe Schärfe also man verkauft den
Chinesen keine Chips mehr man macht
jetzt diesen Inflation reduction Act der
gegen die Welthandelsorganisation gegen
die Statuten verstößt gut das hat sogar
auch habe schon mitbekommen dass das
vielleicht nicht ganz so gutes für
andere Länder also man macht er wirklich
härteste Industriepolitik wenn Trump das
macht dann heißt es ja oh der böse Trump
wenn beiden das macht habe ich das
Gefühl zumindest bei uns interessiert
eigentlich gar nicht jede Entscheidung
in der tramzeit war falsch aber
er hat ganz systematisch das
Zusammenspiel zwischen den Völkern
unterminiert und das ist ein natürlich
ein Problem
der Weltregierung am Ende des Tages
wissen wir das leider hinnehmen wenn
immer die Amerikaner wählen er ist aber
als Underdog als aussider als
protestfigur gestartet und das kann er
nicht mehr jetzt könnt ihr nach seiner
eigenen Darstellung
zur zum Establishment und ich also ich
glaube schon dass sie Demokraten ihnen
nicht vorstellen werden
die Schwäche Demokraten machen am Start
ja klar
keine Politik der Mitte unsere Schwäche
hat stark gemacht ohne unsere Schwäche
wäre wäre
eine SPD 2 wollten aber es ist ein
anderes machen bitte aber dann machen
wir doch zum Ende meiner These immer
eine Abstimmung und schauen dann mal ob
wir nah oder doch Fernsehen sobald es
dann dazu kommt wer denkt denn das
Donald Trump es schafft die Republikaner
also nicht Präsident werden aber für die
Präsidentschaft war antreten zu dürfen
ich sag ich sage ja ja also eine Stimme
er wird die Präsidentschaft zwar
antreten dürfen nein nein und zwar
nachdem ich mit den republikörnern
geredet habe okay nach der Erfahrung in
Israel ja also im Gegensatz zu den
Demokraten haben die Republikaner ja
nachwuchsgründer da sind ja tatsächlich
ein paar Talente wenn die den Mut haben
zu sagen ja bin bereit ich versuch's
dann glaube ich nicht dass das wird ja
auf jeden Fall gegen Kandidaten bekommen
also sagen sie nein also ich glaube
nicht dass Donald Trump der nächste
Präsidenten publikaner antreten okay
also nein ja ja nein ich bin
auch für nein sonst wäre ich für ja
gewesen aber ohne Ivanka glaube ich wird
das gar nichts werden aber wir haben ja
auch hier eigentlich in Deutschland
genug Probleme Herr Heimann und haben
sie uns ja heute eine These zum
mitgebracht wir sind ja gerade auch
nicht das man kann sagen in der Hinsicht
jetzt nicht was war ein betrifft das
Paradebeispiel für die ganze Welt ja und
zwar gleich zweimal also erstens sind
die Wahlen schon peinlich genug wenn man
dann noch weiß dass
der Bundeswahlleiter das ist ja nicht
eine Person das ist ja ein ganzes Amt
vorher schriftlich wie München mündlich
gewarnt hat und die haben einfach nicht
zugehört und dann haben sie es trotzdem
falsch gemacht und dann nach wollen Sie
den Schaden ja wegdiskutieren
indem sie jetzt im Bundestag nur 431
Stimmbezirke neu wählen lassen wie man
das eigentlich wirklich begründen kann
habe ich noch nicht verstanden und dann
haben sie ja ernsthaften Papier wird
über 55 Seiten veröffentlicht dass die
Entscheidung vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht eigentlich zu
überprüfen wäre was sie auch für uns
Inhalte ich hoffe fast dass eine aus der
BVV oder so von der SPD dahin rennt weil
sie würden sich in Karlsruhe aus meiner
Sicht eine abholen
aber wenn man es jetzt zusammenfasst sie
fordern
Neuwahlen
Bundesebene auf Bundesebene ist die
leider komplizierter die Lage warum jede
Nachwahl schafft neue Ungerechtigkeiten
und deswegen hat das Verfassungsgericht
wie ich finde sehr überzeugend
entschieden in Berlin machen wir es dann
sozusagen gleichmäßig dann ist zwischen
den WLAN niemanden benachteiligt das
geht im Bund ja nicht dann müsste man ja
die ganze Bundestagswahl wiederholen 15
Länder die nichts damit zu tun haben
müssen nur das geht nicht zweitens sind
Fehler sind bestimmte Fehler nur in
Berlin passiert insbesondere diese
vertauschten Stimmzettel drittens
dadurch dass die Ergebnisse bei so viel
mehr Wahlkreisen in Berlin so viel
knapper waren kommt viel mehr also wenn
50 Stimmen fehlen und 1000 Leute durften
nicht richtig wählen dann ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass das was
ausmachen natürlich größer als wenn sie
10.000 Stimmen Vorsprung haben und 3000
Leute konnten nicht richtig wählen da
kann das Ergebnis ja nicht anders sein
das Problem
kann man das überhaupt noch ernst nehmen
also da fragt man sich ja wirklich es
ist ja wie sieht Autounfall die Frage
die sich ganz billigen
ist die Spitze des Eisberges einer nicht
funktionierenden öffentlichen Verwaltung
eines nicht funktionierenden
öffentlichen Sektors und das muss
dringend ändern werden und da ist der
Flughafen war ein Fanal und jetzt sind
die Wahlen ein Kanal aber es gibt ja
noch viele andere Dinge nirgendwo muss
man so lange am Standesamt auf einen
Termin warten heiraten zu können die
Bürgerämter Termine klappen seit Jahren
die Schulsanierung klappt nicht also es
ist ja was wäre jetzt die Lösung mehr
Personal einfach oder nein also das ist
leider so verkannte dass man mehrere
Lösung gleichzeitig machen muss wir
brauchen sicher auch zusätzliches
Personal von ihm machen wir das richtige
Personal in den richtigen Stellen die
richtig geführt werden wir brauchen
andere Entscheidungsstrukturen wir haben
ja Entscheidungsstrukturen bei der es
gegenseitige Blockaden gibt also das
Umweltamt sagt der Baum bleibt die
Feuerwehr sagt damit sie ausbauen können
die Feuerwehr sagt der Baum muss weg
sonst kann ich nicht Anleitern diese
Entscheidung bleiben einfach so sind
aber erkennbar widersprüchlich und es
gibt gar keinen System wie es auflösen
können
feststellen würde wird sich denn
überhaupt was ändern jetzt bei Neuwahlen
oder wird sowieso wieder die Regierung
bleiben mit den Farben links bleiben
also jetzt bin ich bekennender und
überzeugt der Bayer und Münchner ich
stecke jetzt nicht ganz so tief in der
Berliner Landespolitik drin aber die
Landtagswahl in Berlin komplett
natürlich auch wenn sie Bayer sind
natürlich also wir schauen schon immer
ein bisschen auf Berlin war ja auch viel
von unserem Geld hier verbaut ist
also was ich also ich denke schon leider
so wie ich das für alle deutschen
zuständig oder natürlich bin ich auf
alle deutschen zuständig deswegen
schauen wir das auch überall gut geht
und gerade in Berlin muss natürlich auch
an als Bundespolitik an ein oder anderen
Stelle nachjustieren die bauen
Wohnungspolitik ist eine Katastrophe
hier übrigens auch gegen die Empfehlung
aller Experten so durchgezogen mit
verheerenden Ergebnisse aber meine Frage
zu beantworten ich also es hängt
natürlich ich weiß nicht davon ab wie in
die CDU aufstellt ob die CDU und starten
Kandidaten aufstellt wir sind als FDP
mit Sebastian gut aufgestellt der wird
die FDP auch in den Wahlkampf führen ich
befürchte schon dass dann gewisses ich
glaube man lernt in Berlin nicht so
wirklich wir werden Ihre Berliner FDP
Freunde denn mehr stimmen wollen können
also ich hoffe sehr wir sind sehr gut
aufgestellt ja doch also es ist es sind
ein paar unbekannte da also deswegen
kann ich mir schwer das jetzt absolut zu
sagen also wir stehen gut da wir sind
noch ein Umfragen bei 7%, das ist für
die FDP sehr sehr stabil es gibt viele
Themen Heimat hat ein paar angesprochen
die auch für uns sehr sehr relevant sind
die Frage ist was ist die Macht Option
also gibt es eine gibts Mehrheit gegen
Rot-Rot-Grün und dann braucht sie die
FDP und das ist für uns ein Thema das
ist sehr sehr stark wir wollen damit
regieren wir haben viele Ideen ähm für
Berlin und berlin braucht eine bessere
Regierung deswegen glaube ich schon wenn
jetzt die Zeit reicht den Wahlkampf gut
zu führen dass die FDP stärker
aussteigen wird das überhaupt aber
wieder der FDP noch die CDU hat
Alternativen dargestellt ich kenne ganz
viele Leute die die von da Wolke
Wahlkabinen standen und nicht
entscheiden konnten auf Berliner Ebene
weil es ist nicht nur rot rot grün
sondern werden sie die EU das behält
sich wie ein SPD 2 und FDP die zwei
behalten also alternativ
das was viele Berliner eigentlich schon
viel vor also was haben alternative
Entscheidung was haben sie waren ja auch
an die Macht und da hat sich nicht
aussprechen sein Punkt fertig machen ja
sie haben ja auch die waren das ist
nicht dass wir seit Jahrzehnten rot rot
grün gehabt haben sie waren ja auch in
Berlin teil der Koalition und da hat
sich nichts verändert also wir haben
auch große Koalition und ich ich glaube
das was was ich alles Berliner fühle von
auch ganz ganz viele anderen wir haben
keine Alternativen und ja mit grün grün
grün mit grün rot grün rot rot grün ist
katastrophal aber mit ihnen und mit
ihnen haben wir keine Alternative tut
mir leid drei Punkte das erste ist in
der Amtszeit von der großen Koalition
die ja nur fünf Jahre dauert heute haben
wir den Berliner Haushalt saniert und
einen Aufschwung für Berlin organisiert
wie in Wien noch nicht gesehen haben das
wird zwar immer
weggewischt war aber so wir hatten
bessere Zahlen beim Wohnungsbau größere
Zahlen als wir heute haben sie waren
immer noch nicht gut genug aber sie
waren klar steigend und sie waren besser
was wir nicht hinbekommen haben auch das
ist Teil der Wahrheit ist eine
vernünftige Verwaltungs Modernisierung
dafür ist Frank Henkel damals auch
abgestraft worden
jetzt bei der letzten Wahl war es so
dass die Berliner landesthemen ja gar
nicht so richtig zu Vorschein kam weil
wir gleichzeitig Bundestagswahl haben
das wird ja jetzt im Februar anders
werden
kleine Aufklärung kein Wegner wird unser
Spitzenkandidat werden die und wir haben
beide Frage des Wohnungsbaus bei der
Frage der Wirtschaftsförderung
inzwischen bei der Frage wie macht man
eigentlich Verwaltungs Modernisierung
insbesondere auch Berlin ist ja auch
Schlusslicht beim Thema Klimaschutz 22
Gebäude öffentliche Gebäude von 1000
haben ein Solar Dach die quatschen hier
auch nur und machen nicht ja und ähm und
zweiten haben sie vergessen Integration
und Kriminalität die die die es gibt
noch mehr Themen ist gar keine Frage
aber ich und natürlich müssten wir beim
Thema durch
Grenzen von polizeilichen Mitteln bei
der Bekämpfung des Themas dass sie sehr
beschäftigt nicht zusammengefasst also
man kann das ja immer mit so zahlen und
so schön reden aber irgendwie hat man ja
schon das Gefühl hier in Berlin klappt
einfach nix und Herr Mansour hat gerade
was tut sie nicht so da geben sie da
sind wir schon mal alleine Meinung und
Sie haben gerade was ganz spannendes
angesprochen dass sie das Gefühl haben
dass auch FDP und Union Mogelpackungen
sind und eigentlich ich habe gerade
gesagt haben so dass dass die zum Teil
nicht durchgedrungen sind es leider auch
die Wahrheit aber die ähm wir haben
durchaus Alternativen man muss ja nichts
klar sagen wird man wird in fünf Jahren
das
Verwaltungssystem in Berlin nur
schrittweise umbauen können das heißt
nicht wenn morgen die CDU regiert haben
sie übermorgen überall Bürgeramt Termine
sagen dass das nicht klappt das Problem
ist so tief dass man dafür auch eine
radikale braucht ein Bürger zuhört und
Politiker sagt also in fünf Jahren kann
ich da jetzt nichts groß verändern
vielleicht ist es ehrlich aber es ist
weit technisch nicht so klug oder naja
aber ehrlich gesagt es gibt ja auch noch
mal einen Tag nach der Wahl und wenn sie
jetzt lauter versprechen machen die sie
dann am Tag nach der Wahl gleich wieder
einkassieren müssen ich glaube die
Bürger wollen über die weiteren es ist
ein ganz verfestigtes Problem dass wir
seit Jahrzehnten in Berlin haben und
dazu warten wir sehr starke Maßnahmen
vorliegen
Berlin droht der verwaltungsnotstand
weil es lauter Faktoren gibt die das
Problem noch verschärfen will ein
Drittel des öffentlichen Dienstes geht
in diesem jahrzehn im Pension ich musste
es gibt
keine digitalen Systeme
drei Punkte drei Punkte würde ich gerne
mal machen in dem Kontext gerne also
genau das ist eigentlich die Tragik der
CDU in Berlin das viele vier Probleme
beschreiben das kann ich auch das können
auch viele Leute wir wollen Lösungen
weil wir satt haben dass wir in Berlin
als Arbeiten der Menschen nicht der
Service nicht die das bekommen was ein
normaler Bürger in ein Land wie
Deutschland kommen soll und das ist das
Problem also bitten Sie bitte Lösungen
und ich bin der erste dabei ihnen bin
also muss ich nochmal drei drei Punkte
machen weil wir auch mit angesprochen
sind
in Bayern Fußball
machen kann was was was mir von außen
relevant entscheiden und die FDP Berlin
Wahlprogramm in Berlin braucht eine
Strukturreform sie haben in diese
Bezirksämter zu viel eigene Macht
ausgelagert die sich widersprechen da
ist tatsächlich die Struktur ähnlich ähm
wie wir auch mal über eine Föderalismus
in Deutschland reden müssen da hat
Berlin eine Struktur aufgebaut die muss
geändert werden das ist jetzt ein
technisches Thema das wird
wahrscheinlich kein Wähler hinter dem
Ofen hervorholen aber da müssen wichtig
zweitens wenn Hermann so als Berliner
sagt wir beide bieten keine Alternative
dann müssen wir ernst nehmen dann wäre
ich jetzt nicht erzählen was ich alles
Tolles gemacht hat für Berlin sondern da
müssen wir schauen wie erreichen unsere
Botschaften die Berlinerin Wähler und
Wähler das ist die zweite wichtige
Aufgabe der wir uns verpflichtet fühlen
und das dritte
also die Feststellung wir brauchen die
richtigen Leute zur richtigen Zeit in
der richtigen Stelle und die müssen wir
gut bezahlen das ist ja in Zeiten des
Fachkräftemangel mangels einfach
Wunschdenken die Struktur angehen die
Verwaltung digitalisieren sie müssen in
die Bildung investieren und zwar so dass
es kracht das ist Kraft weil von außen
zu machen
in Deutschland mittlerweile auch schon
leider keiner mehr also da reden wir
jetzt gefühlt seit 10 Jahren drüber und
das Problem ist doch auch bei diesen
ganzen Strukturen irgendwie entflechten
das Ganze zusammen kürzen das
funktioniert doch nicht im Endeffekt so
ein Staat der immer größer wird der
müsste sich ja selber abschaffen das ist
ja genau wie eine Arbeiterpartei die
sich eigentlich auf die Fahnen schreibt
den Arbeitern muss es gut gehen aber
wenn Sie ihn gut gehen würde dann wäre
quasi die Arbeit der Partei am Ende und
ich glaube einfach nicht dass ich der
Bundestag wird immer größer
welche Struktur schaffen auch und das
kostet auch noch absolut welche Struktur
schaffen
immer nur nach großen Krisen so und
Berlin muss wahrscheinlich die Krise
groß genug sein dass wir den Mut haben
die Entscheidungen zu treffen ich muss
die Krise in Berlin dennoch werden
eine gute Überleitung wir müssen noch
mehr abstürzen ich glaube Herr Lochner
glaubt das werden wir sowieso weil wir
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck haben
wenn ich das mal so ausdrücken kann ihre
These die sie aber jetzt selber verraten
ja am Tisch ja was erwartet man von
einem Bundeskanzler der das Sparbuch
empfiehlt und auch er von einem
Wirtschaftsminister den ich persönlich
nicht mal eine Pommesbude führen lassen
würde das mit der Insolvenz muss ich
jetzt noch mal wiederholen ja es ist
einfach in unserer Regierung glaube ich
ist mangelt an ja finanzieller Bildung
bzw der finanzpolitischen Entscheidungen
die uns einfach nach vorne bringen vor
allem wenn man sich mal überlegt wie es
um uns steht also unsere Rente liegt ja
schon auf der Intensivstation wir stehen
jetzt vor einer heftigen Rezession also
gut die Aktienmärkte die machen
tatsächlich noch eine erstaunlich gute
Figur Natur aber man muss ja auch mal
klar machen was da schon eingepreist ist
also der aktienmarktpreis der bei
Unternehmen wie VW schon eigentlich ein
dass das China Geschäft quasi schon
weggebrochen ist also man muss immer
vorstellen was da momentan alles
gespielt wird was da auf dem Spiel steht
und ja ich würde mir da mehr Politiker
wünschen wie Herrn Hallmann der ja
erfolgreicher Unternehmer ist oder ja
das ist ja schon fast untertrieben
Heilmann fragen wir doch mal ihn ob er
denn Herbeck die Pommesbude anvertrauen
würde die gerade als Beispiel genannt
wurde
Oppositionspolitiker bin kann man ja
auch verschweigen und genießen oder von
außen angegriffen wird ich bin ja auf
der anderen Seite ich glaube das mit der
Pommesbude ist eine leichte Übertreibung
ich würde es etwas sachlicher sagen aber
die Regierung und zwar auch ihre FDP
muss ich sagen hat capital alle Fehler
gemacht das geht damit los dass die
gasumlage 5 Monate lang von uns bekämpft
von ihnen auch erinnert Abgeordneter
mehrfach dafür im Bundestag geschimpft
um dann plötzlich ein Lindner zu sagen
ah die gasumlage die erhöht ja die
Gaspreise eigentlich wollen wir sie ja
selber 180 Grad Wände die viel zu spät
kam jetzt haben wir haben wir bei der
gaspreisbremse weder für die Unternehmen
noch für die Bürger Klarheit wir kriegt
eigentlich wann etwas
lieber als die FDP und damit Christian
Lindner ich finde das ist ein
Teamleistung da eine schlechte
Teamleistung und ich weiß jetzt nicht
aber sie können natürlich so wie beim
Fußball auch Noten geben und da haben
sie dann habe ich jetzt sehr schlechte
Noten gegeben aber ich würde anderen
auch schlechte Noten geben
halte Vorwürfe an sie hier als
FDP-Politiker in der Runde die FDP
machen schlecht Job wenn ich jetzt mal
so übersetzen kann
da habe ich jetzt naturgemäß eine andere
Meinung ich weiß wir werden
mist ich gebe noch einen zweiten Fehler
zu aus dem Habeck Haus des förderchaos
beim Bauen und Wohnen in diesem Jahr war
eine Katastrophe also ja es sind Fehler
passiert der Punkt ist wir müssen sie
abstellen jetzt kannst bei der Gasanlage
zu lange gedauert haben immer das ist
sie kennen meine Position Heilmann das
war das war zu lang ich will auch nicht
ausreden der Punkt ist
wir werden ihrer Fraktion
führen sie mich nicht in Versuchung mit
ihnen mit Zitat aus ihrer Fraktion zu
kommen wenn wir beide echt nicht mehr
glücklich wollen der Punkt ist ja
mittlerweile entlastungspakete geschnürt
die 300 Milliarden Euro aussumieren plus
200 Milliarden Euro um die härtesten
zwei die hättesten Energie und Gaspreise
abzufedern das muss gemacht werden die
Opposition weiß es immer besser die CDU
liegt die Pläne zwar nie vor die kommt
immer erst hinterher hat meistens die
Idee gegeben noch mehr Geld aus aber der
Punkt ist bei der Frage habe die
Pommesbude was ja wirklich also was ja
schon stimmt wurde anvertrauen also
nicht meine die würde ich selber führen
aber also er habe begreift sich viel zu
sehr als klimaminister und viel zu
weniger als Wirtschaftsminister also
stimmt schon da kann man jetzt sagen
okay ich bin der FDP ich bin Regierungs
tragen sie nämlich dann mit Haftung aber
ich also wir arbeiten ja schon dagegen
ich weiß dass es dass wir nicht dafür
gewählt werden was wir verhindern
aber immer ehrlich ne also was wir
vorgefunden haben nach 16 Jahren und was
wir jetzt draus machen und in einer
Geschwindigkeit in einer Geschwindigkeit
ich weiß geht euch nicht schnell genug
wenn ein Geschwindigkeit krempeln wir
gerade das Land um weil wir es viele
Sachen aufholen müssen die nicht
funktionieren jetzt mal erstmal
so und bleiben einmal auch bei der Leben
zu Realität die ja jeder wahrscheinlich
von uns allein schon beim Einkaufen
empfindet ja ich finde es schon sehr
teuer geworden aber wir sehen sie das
denn eigentlich bin heute in der
Vertreter der kleinen Mensch
ich will einfach die Realität
wiedergeben und wir haben vor der
Sendung noch ein bisschen gesprochen ich
was mir fehlt ist diese Bekenntnis
sowohl stand und Wachstum ich glaube das
fällt komplett und das bedeutet dass wir
hier ganz andere Prioritäten haben die
die Bürger und Bürgerinnen noch nicht
mitbekommen haben das ist hier um dass
die Klima dass die
antikapitalistische zweite Reihe bei den
Grünen und auch die SPD eigentlich das
ganze System in Frage stellen und sie
ehrlich sind dann sollen sich das bitte
die Menschen auch draußen sagen und da
geht es nicht nur um Teuerung von
Lebensmittel die die Menschen hinnehmen
und also in anderen Ländern gehen die
Leute auf der Straße ich habe noch nie
gesehen dass die Menschen hier einfach
auch ihre Unmut auch nach
außenalisierung vor allem auch ja und um
Klima was sich auch Teile was ich mehr
davon machen will als die Priorität
Nummer eins und nicht Wohlstand und
nicht Wachstum und nicht Wirtschaft also
du würdest die Prioritäten verschieben
und Wohlstand und Wachstum auf einsetzen
ja absolut natürlich
darum er wie verteile ich um also das
jetzt vielleicht Milliardär ein bisschen
mehr Steuern zahlen kann okay aber dass
man wirklich hier ständig ähm ja da
glaube ich sind auch viele Wähler von
der FDP enttäuscht auch wenn sicherlich
natürlich schwierig ist aber ich glaube
es wäre schon geboten wirklich die Leute
die hart arbeiten und man ist in
Deutschland mit 60 000 € oder
wir brauchen sehr viele Sachen wir
brauchen sicherlich eine
steuerrechtliche Entlastung ich finde
wir brauchen noch mal Diskussionen wenn
ein Mensch in Deutschland 30.000 Euro im
Jahr verdient ich frage mich warum muss
der überhaupt noch Steuern zahlen also
ich glaube darüber kann man einfach mal
diskutieren weil das ist ja gerade bei
dieser Inflation wir kommen beide aus
München wenn ich in München sowas
verdiene hätte hatte Sachen der FDP hier
vorzuwerfen dass sie die Steuern nicht
gesenkt kriegen das verstehe ich in der
Koalition das kriegen keine Mehrheit ich
will aber sagen sie haben da gerade so
gesagt Sie haben nicht 300 Milliarden
verteilt sondern sie haben 300
Milliarden Schulden aufgenommen und noch
gar nichts verteilt weil die ganzen
Gesetze gibt es alle noch gar nicht wir
haben große technische Schwierigkeiten
wir haben ein Digital also ich
persönlich verantwortlich dafür einen
Plan für die man die ganze Gas und
energiepreisbremse digital machen könnte
und nicht mit diesem Irrsinn der
doppelten Verrechnung und jeder
Energieversorger 400 müssen alle
umprogrammieren ich sage Ihnen sind
alles schief gehen so wie es da geht und
wir haben Alternativen dazu vorgelegt
wir sagen lieber wenige kriegen 1.000
Euro alle 300 auch das wäre mit einem
digitalen System möglich insofern haben
wir sehr wohl Alternativen vorgelegt und
wir haben das vor allen Dingen alles
halt April gesagt und jetzt noch was mit
der Vorgängerregierung den energiekrieg
haben sie nicht angefangen sondern Putin
aber wir auch nicht und dann haben Frage
stellen im Bundestag geht es da
eigentlich um Lösung und Inhalte oder
kann ich mir das so vorstellen wie heute
Abend hier da sind verschiedene Parteien
die eigentlich immer mit sich selbst
beschäftigt sind werden was schönes ist
und wer eigentlich böse ist wie auf dem
Pausenhof ist es sehr interessiert es
geht
wirklich und wir brauchen hier wir
brauchen eine Strafe
innerhalb der Ampel wir haben wir haben
ja wir haben ja tatsächlich also wir
haben ja wir haben ja tatsächlich der
Bundestag unter demokratie braucht eine
starke Opposition stellt keine müssen in
der FDP nicht in Frage und dann muss
auch viel kommen aber jetzt einfach zu
sagen wir digitalisieren jetzt die
gaspreisbremse obwohl unser Land 0,0
digital ist wir die größte größte
wohngeldreform seit dem Krieg auf den
Weg gebracht die Kommunen sagen uns wir
kriegen die nicht gewuppt weil wir zu
viel mit der Bürokratie zu tun haben so
und jetzt zu sagen die Lösung ist
Menschen digitalisiert das doch noch
schnell dann geht es alles das ist nicht
realistisch
vorgeschlagen hat was mich auch brennend
interessiert und ich hoffe sie alle am
Tisch auch ich fand die Frage gerade
ganz spannend diese gestellt haben warum
muss jemand der 30 000 € Jahreseinkommen
hat das auch noch versteuern warum lässt
man den Bürger nicht mehr Geld das ist
ja wirklich eine Frage die sehr sehr
spannend ist aber nicht die Steuern
sondern die Sozialabgaben die ihr
bezahlt das ist nämlich viel viel mehr
Geld als die Steuererklärung man könnte
mit den Steuer anfangen ich will auch
sofort dafür gibt es keine Mehrheit im
Deutschen Bundestag und gab es schon
vorher nicht weil wir ja mit der
spd-kolliert haben deswegen ging es auch
vorher nicht aber das eigentliche
Problem ist natürlich die Sozialabgaben
sie haben völlig mit Recht die Rente
angesprochen die natürlich teurer wird
das ist gar keine Frage weil einfach
mehr Leute alt werden und wenn dann mein
Jahrgang der stärkste je war pro Person
geht dann jedes Jahr schon mehr als 100
Milliarden rein die die der der
eigentliche die eigentliche Frage sind
die Sozialabgaben und ähm der
Sozialstaat wird in einem Maße teuer das
irgendwann die Leute sehr sehr viel Geld
von ihrem verdienten Geld abgeben müssen
und die FDP hat
ist jetzt gerade dabei sich für einen
Bürgergeld einzusetzen dass wir im
Bundesrat erstmal gestoppt haben bei der
man wie bitte das ist Wahnsinn der
absolute Wahnsinn so und wir sind
übrigens weil sie das so eben gesagt
haben wir sind dazu da die Regierung zu
kritisieren unser Job und wir können
momentan nicht selber reden abgewählt
worden sind wir hinnehmen also sind wir
diejenigen beurteilen zusammenfassen da
gibt es wenn es da eine eine also wenn
ich jetzt einmal zusammenfassen darf die
Steuerentlastung oder auch die Abgaben
gibt es nicht wegen der SPD die ja
eigentlich dafür da ist dem kleinen Mann
zu helfen das Wort ist übrigens ihr blöd
von Politikern gewählt aber so ist
die SPD hat sehr sehr viel blockiert was
wir gerne gemacht hätten das nicht so
richtig Ausrede sagen und dasselbe
Problem hat jetzt die FDP deswegen darf
ich sie nicht vor
das ist nun mal so mehr Zeit ist es sind
so wie sie sind das haben die Bilder so
entschieden deswegen gibt es eine zu
hohe Staatsquote in Deutschland und im
übrigen natürlich auch irgendwann werden
Schulden gehen nie weg Schulden werden
bleiben und das ist noch viel größere
Problem als der Wachstum ist das
Schuldenproblem wenn ich jetzt einmal
das Wort noch habe in einem Punkt bin
ich nicht ihrer Meinung der Klimawandel
wenn wir den nicht aufhalten das wird
die teuerste Veranstaltung die wir uns
überhaupt je vorgestellt haben weil das
wahnsinnig viele Konflikte darstellt der
amerikanische Begriff ist
geleitet also das heißt der Fahrstuhl
mit den Problemen in 3 Milliarden Leute
nicht da bleiben können wo sie heute
leben weil es klimatisch nicht mehr geht
sie kommen ja auch direkt von der
Klimakonferenz
das Thema
schlechthin
aber wenn sie wenn wir wenn wir den
klima wandel
stoppen wollen dann müssen wir auf
Innovationen sitzen da müssen wir auf
Wachstum setzen ich würde sogar
weitergehen auf verzichten und wir
brauchen ein marktwirtschaftliches
System das diesen wachstumsvertrag das
Wachstum belohnt im Bereich der
Klimatechnik und die Innovation befeuert
aber ich habe jetzt einen dringendes
Bedürfnis noch mal darauf zu reagieren
auf die Rente ja unsere Sozialsystem
steht vor dem Kollaps es ist jetzt ein
Einstieg gelungen zwar nur mit 10
Milliarden aber es sind immerhin 10
Milliarden immerhin aber auch leider
gedecktes System ein bisschen weniger
aber es ist uns bewegen
aufgegangen also wir müssen unsere
Sozialsysteme tatsächlich umbauen da
gibt's die einen Seite die sagt naja
dann sollen die Leute immer mehr zahlen
das ist nicht unsere
Positionierung müssen verzichten anders
wäre es gar nicht zu schaffen deswegen
gibt es ja auch eine gewisse
Rentenformel aber wichtig ist dass wir
Sozialsysteme umbauen und noch mal beim
Punkt der Entlastung
beim 1,3-fachen des durchschnittlichen
Lohns ist man schon eine
Spitzensteuersatz
natürlich sind die Sozialabgaben
ich habe das sogar vor wenigen Tagen
nachgeschaut extra da ist dann der
Unterschied zwischen 1700 netto nur
steuern und das das sind dann schon die
Steuern das ist jetzt nicht die Welt
aber das ist vielleicht genauso ja genau
also gerade wenn man so wenig verdient
dann ist es vielleicht auch Geld dass
man investieren kann und den Menschen
mehr lassen
wir also was wir jetzt machen es wird
glaube ich dieses Jahr noch fertig oder
Anfang nächstes Jahr wir werden es
mindestens das Bausparen neu an ähm
reizenzen mehr Kapital
gehen danach gibt's bestimmt noch mal
Wahlkampf nein das werde ich verhindern
wir machen gleich weiter mit spannenden
Themen bis gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist das fast
total
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glööckler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst
haben wir haben zu viel Staaten werden
die alle wegfallen und wir uns
gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte Cappuccinos
verkaufen das funktioniert nicht dann
ist mit Wohlstand das ist alles essen
als freiheitsliebender Mensch würde ich
sagen das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen unser Land fordert dann müsst
ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch was
machbar sein ich finde aber diese
gesamte Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch
ein bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt mit dem wir reden soll
[Musik]
Ausbeutung wir sind zurück und es geht
jetzt weiter mit dem Häusle bauen also
ob man sich heutzutage eigentlich noch
ein Haus leisten kann ein Eigenheim und
das machen wir mit dem FDP Politiker
Herr fest
ich halte es für ganz entscheidend dass
wir den Menschen auf dem Weg ins
Eigenheim helfen es ist nicht nur der
Wunsch aller jede Umfrage zeigt die
Menschen wollen in den eigenverbänden
wohnen es ist ja auch gesellschaftlichen
strebenswertes Team mehr Eigentum
Deutschland ist ja leider fast
Schlusslicht in Europa mehr Eigentum
schließt die die vermögenspreizung es
ist sichert die Person die es schafft
vor Altersarmut und übrigens auch die
Nachfolge Generation und wenn es uns
gelingt Viertel zu durchmischen nicht
nur sozial sondern Mietwohnung und
Eigentumswohnung dann sind die auch
stabiler aber derzeit ist es schwierig
das ist mir klar nur wenn es in einer
akuten Krise aber da dürfen wir aber die
längeren Pläne nicht aus den Augen
verlieren und deswegen sage ich wenn es
jetzt schwierig ist dann müssen wir erst
recht angreifen das Deutschland eine
Eigentum dazu wird nicht nur als
Menschen wollen sondern weil es auch gut
für die Gesellschaft ist Deutschland ist
ja in Europa weit abgeschlagen was die
eigenheimquote betrifft woran liegt es
denn haben wir nicht das Geld dafür
zögern wir woran liegt das oder lässt
der Staat uns vielleicht einfach vom zu
wenig netto fürs Eigenheim es sind
tatsächlich viele Faktoren ja meiner
Meinung nach lässt uns der Staat auch zu
wenig vom Brutto mit Netto vom Brutto
war er tatsächlich auch mal eine sehr
prominente Forderung die wir wieder
aufleben lassen müssten aber wir haben
mehrere Faktoren zum einen wir haben
sehr sehr starkes Mietrecht das
Bundesverfassungsgericht spricht bei
Mietrecht von Eigentums ähnlichen
Verhältnissen das zweite wir haben ein
Angebotslücke es ist zu wenig Wohnraum
da sowohl zu Miete als auch fürs
Eigentum das dritte ist die Preise
steigen enorm teilweise getrieben durch
Regulierung des Staates da können wir
sehr originär eingreifen und das vierte
ist auf dem Weg ins Eigentum ich habe zu
hohe Kaufnebenkosten und ich habe zu
viel Ansprüche eines eigenen aber ich
habe so viel Notwendigkeit Eigenkapital
mitzubringen und wenn wir da an allen
diesen Stellen ansetzen das geht nicht
gleichzeitig es geht nicht gleichzeitig
dieses Wort überall aber wir müssen
anfangen
mehr geil es gibt ja noch einen anderen
Grund warum Menschen nicht mehr bauen
ist die Bauvorschriften die sind in
Deutschland ja auch wirklich fast schon
die Zar kann man sagen braucht viele gar
keine Lust haben sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen wie es denn da ihre
Erfahrungen mit ja also erstens da sind
wir einer Meinung zweitens zum Thema
Bauvorschriften ich habe ein besonders
kurioses Beispiel das ist schön ich
hätte auch eins bieten können ja wir
geben in Deutschland inzwischen 10
Milliarden Euro jährlich für Brandschutz
aus haben aber seit 30 Jahren keine
sinkenden Todeszahlen von Brandopfern
also sollte die mit einer Zigarette im
Bett einschlafen die die trifft es
leider manchmal und Sterben das ist aber
da können sie so viel Brandschutztüren
einbauen wie Sie wollen die sterben ja
an dem Dampf in dem Zimmer jedenfalls
sie sehen überhaupt gar keine also wenn
wir beide wir warten immer bei 20.000
Verkehrstoten im Jahr bei weniger
Verkehrs haben wir mehr Verkehr und
leider immer noch 3000 aber das ja schon
mal weniger Geld investiert da haben wir
noch ein Ergebnis beim Brandschutz Null
es finden Sie mal den Politiker der sagt
ähm und da möchte man die Medien sehen
wir machen jetzt meine
brandschutzvorschrift Weg die muss gar
nicht mehr sein Vergessens haben sie
ganz industrie-lobby gegen sich aber sie
finden auch immer irgendeinen Professor
der sagt es ist totaler Wahnsinn also
wie kann man denn die Gefährten die
armen Schüler die dann in der Schule
sitzen oder in der Brand so also
deswegen wird es sich keiner trauen
Politiker vielleicht Geld bekommen für
jede Vorschrift die sie abschaffen und
für jedes gibt ja wirklich viele in
diesem Land
vielleicht wäre das ein Anreiz wieso
Bonussystems der auf Stahl oben drauf
sein müssen wir erhöht weiß kein Mensch
das würde aber enorm Steigerung
Kostensteigerungen das wird natürlich
auch dazu weniger Trittschall wer mit
Dämmerung ist auch ein Problem das macht
das Haus auch noch mal teuer
ist besonders also die Leute geben mehr
Geld dafür aus dass in der Altbauwohnung
sind wo sie ihren Nachbarn viel stärker
erholen eine Neubauwohnung haben sie
fast die Verhältnisse von dem
Fernsehstudio
ja die Thema energetische
Gebäudesanierung was natürlich wichtig
ist dass man da auch die Gebäude
Klimaschutz nach vorne bringen aber das
ist natürlich ein riesen Problem wenn
man mit Immobilienexperten spricht die
dir wirklich tief drin sind dass das so
ein Unsicherheitsfaktor ist dass da
einfach viele sich ja wahrscheinlich gar
nicht mehr trauen werden also die Sachen
jetzt auch loswerden wollen weil das
einfach so ein Risiko ist unberechenbar
es gibt natürlich von der Politik schon
gewisse Pläne aber das ist alles noch
ein bisschen undurchschaubar da kann ich
natürlich erst Investor dann auch schwer
kalkulieren also da kommen sicherlich
auch noch ja einige Probleme das ist
alles noch so ein bisschen in der
Schwebe ähm dann haben das
inflationsproblem Fertigstellung Risiken
das auf einmal Keller wenn Sie heute
noch das eigene Tun das Eigenheims
Investitionen empfehlen gerade nicht
also gerade ist das immer schwer jetzt
eine kurzfristige Prognose zu treffen
aber wir hatten jetzt natürlich eine
extreme vermögenspreis Inflation in den
letzten Jahren auch getrieben durch die
niedrigen Zinsen das hat sich jetzt das
kommt euch jetzt natürlich nicht so
dagegen mit dem Vorhaben jetzt gerade
die Zinsentwicklung mal schauen wie
nachhaltig ist wie weit es noch geht
aber momentan kippt das ganze bzw es ist
schon gekippt und wenn man mit Leuten
spricht die da wirklich ganz tief drin
sind ich habe mir jetzt auch manche das
Problem ihre Kredite nicht mehr bedienen
zu können genau klar also es ist
natürlich immer schwer jetzt deutscher
Markt amerikanischer Markt das ist immer
schwer das kann man sich alles in einen
Topf werfen aber da ist schon einiges
jetzt gerade ist schon gekippt ist noch
am kippen Immobilienmarkt ist natürlich
sehr träge das ist nicht wieder
Aktienmarkt dass das innerhalb von ein
paar Tagen geht sondern da muss
natürlich erstmal einiges in Gang kommen
aber man hört da schon sehr viele Sachen
dass er gewisse Projekte sehr schwer
verkauft werden und dass man jetzt dann
aber das ist natürlich auch teilweise es
hat auch Vorteile dass man vielleicht in
einen Käufermarkt genau kommen könnte
wieder und das ist das tatsächlich eine
sehr interessante Entwicklung die wir
beobachten müssen wir haben
alle ihre Argumente hören aber einmal
einmal so auch noch reinholen weil
ansonsten kommt ihr heute auch wirklich
zu kurz wie sieht es denn aus heutzutage
mit dem Bauen man sagt ja immer polnisch
vielleicht auch früher konnte der
Handwerker bauen heutzutage kannst nur
noch der Millionär wie ist es da
ich glaube dass wir vor allem hier in
Berlin aber im großen Städten ein großer
Problem haben dass wir zu wenig
Wohnungen haben dass Menschen wirklich
monatelang warten oder suchen und
manchmal klappt es gar nicht also ich
kenne vor allem ganz viele Flüchtlinge
die wirklich seit Jahren nach eine
Wohnung suchen und das nicht finden in
Berlin das ist ein riesen Problem und
ich glaube dass wir wie sagen in eine
Situation kommen wo Leute die schon ihre
eigenen haben gekauft haben das nicht
mehr leisten können also die Kredite
nicht mehr Leistung und das trifft mich
das trifft auch ganz ganz viele Leute
das ist eine Situation wo ich wünsche
dass halt die Regierung auch irgendwie
Pläne hat um das zu schützen aber ich
sehe wenn weil weltweit anschauen ich
sehe dass die Wohnungsmarkt dass sie
Immobilienmarkt
katastrophaler Entwicklungen vor hat in
den letzten Jahren
können wir rein wir haben zehn Jahre
lang drüber diskutiert dass die sehr
niedrigen Zinsen die Investoren auf den
Markt locken weil man da relativ
sicheres Beton Gold ist da immer das
Begriff Anlage hat die Investoren wir
jetzt durch die Steigung Zinsen
abgeschreckt das heißt es tatsächlich
sehen wir auch Preis Abschwünge
zumindest ja teilweise hängt davon ab wo
sie hinschauen also es wird es wird die
Indizien dass es günstiger werden könnte
sind da wir sind noch nicht überall der
Fall aber damit wäre schon mal was
geworden
günstiger also ich bin ja ich bin ja
nicht hier weil ich mit dem Status kurz
zufrieden bin mir die Politik gegangen
weil ich unzufrieden bin mit dem Status
Quo dann müssen wir gegen leisten
dafür noch verantwortlich sein dass
Menschen bauen also die Anspruchshaltung
die ihr schon da ist der Staat würde
schon richten ob bei Finanzkrise
corona-pandemie
machen genau
hört eingezogen dass es schwieriger
geworden ist und da kann man mit Fug und
Recht verlangen dass die zurückgenommen
werden bestes Beispiel sind die kaufen
Nebenkosten
während dieses Jahr noch auf den Weg
bringen die Liberalisierung der
Grunderwerbsteuer gegenfinanziert durch
es wird ein bisschen technisch sehr
Deals also durch das was unternehmen
Immobilienmarkt machen finanziert
teilweise gegen was Häuslebauer bekommen
um in Freibetrag bei der
Grunderwerbsteuer zu bekommen das ist
eine Hürde die wir die wir tatsächlich
wegnehmen wollen weil er Heilmann zu
Recht in Brandschutz an gesprochen hat
also wenn ich thematisieren Bundestag
freue mich auf ihren Applaus weil wir
ist ja nicht nur dass wir unseren
Brandschutz verschärfen europäische
Nachbarn Österreich Schweiz Polen
Tschechien zeigen uns wie es deutlich
günstiger geht ohne dass die höhere
Todeszahlen hätten also ich muss gar
nicht in die
vergangenen Thema wo man vielleicht doch
mal genauer hinschauen sollte ob alles
so sinnvoll ist ja bauen übrigens der
Schallschutz auch wir haben tatsächlich
die dicksten Betondecken in Europa weil
wir eine Vorstellung haben dass man in
so einer schallkabine leben muss das
kann alles reduziert werden nur und dann
bin ich bei meiner Heimat da braucht man
eine politische Mehrheit wir werden auch
formulieren aber noch ist sie nicht da
beim Naturschutz bin dabei Ihnen das ist
eine harte den Grünen aber in einem
versiegelten Raum also wenn ich in einem
in der Stadt ein Gebäude ergänze aufbaue
ausbaue wenn ich es auch vielleicht
Abreise und Neubau warum brauche ich
dann Umwelt Gutachten das ist ein
versiegelter Raum absolut wir haben auch
ein anderes Problem außer dass bauen und
das spricht heute abend nämlich Ahmad
Mansour an
vielleicht spreche ich gerade ein Thema
die sie nicht so beliebt und nicht gerne
hören wollen es geht eigentlich um den
politischen Islam und den Islamismus vor
allem kurz bevor wir angefangen Fußball
zu gucken in Katar ist nicht nur
gefährlich und problematisch weil sie
8000 Menschen das Leben gekostet hat
beim Baum von Stadien sondern vor allem
weil sie weltweit die islamistische
Strukturen finanzieren auch hier in
Deutschland auch hier in Europa sie
verbreiten Hass sie verbreiten
Antisemitismus sie verbreiten eine Islam
der nicht nur eine Weltreligion ist
sondern vor allem eine politische Macht
haben will und wir gehen damit vorlich
nach ihm wir wollen damit nicht hören
unsere Politiker wollen sich damit nicht
beschäftigen schauen Sie nach Iran wie
möglich die Frauen auf der Straße gehen
was sie zeigen und was machen wir wir
lassen eine Außenposten des iranischen
Regime als Partner von den Staat Hamburg
gelten
islamischer Zentrum Hamburg ist eine
Außenposten des politischen Islam und
war und wir wollen das nicht mehr
irgendwie wahrnehmen und diejenigen die
irgendwie davon warnen sind mittlerweile
Krawallmacher Islamhasser Islam Feinden
Rassisten es trifft mich ich lebe seit
Jahren unter Personenschutz und ich
kriege nicht genug Unterstützung von dem
Politiker die eigentlich das Thema nicht
mehr hören wollen es gibt ja ein Punkt
den viele sagen der Glaube an den
reformierten Islam ist das eine
Möglichkeit dass sie sich vielleicht in
Zukunft bessern könnte weißt du
jahrelang habe ich geglaubt auch alles
Einwanderer dass wenn ein reformierter
Islam wenn ein Islam der mit Demokratie
und Menschenrechte irgendwann entstehen
wird dann wird auf Europa entstehen
aber mittlerweile glaube ich genau also
die europäische Muslime die hier
sozialisiert sie sind die mit Demokratie
und Menschen groß geworden sind das sind
diejenigen die das nach vorne bringen
wollen mittlerweile liberale Moschee in
Berlin genau ja ein Beispiel der
eigentlich von Politik aber auch leider
von vielen Muslima gekämpft werden und
ähm genau
ich schätze ihre Arbeit sehr aber
mittlerweile glaube ich dass wenn der
Reformbewegung kommen soll dann wird sie
aus dem Nahen Osten kommen die iranische
Frauen zeigen uns gerade wie es in
Europa geht und warum weil wir die
falschen hofieren weil wir nicht mehr
mit seran athisch oder mit Ahmet man so
zusammenarbeiten wollen sondern mit ECHA
und mit anderen und das tut die Politik
in allen möglichen Parteien ob das in
Berlin ob das in warum macht die Politik
das weil sie unbedingt diese Religion
die kirchliche Strukturen aufzwingen
wollen sie wollen Ansprechpartner und
diese ansprech Partner sind da das sind
die Tipps das ist ech das ist mir
ligurisch Organisation die Moscheen
haben und man sagt ja sie vertreten die
Muslime hat deshalb nehmen wir sie
machen mit den Islamkonferenz geben vor
der Gelder das ist unglaublich LCH
kriegt Geld da um
derartikalisierungsarbeit zu machen
Gelder um Integrationsarbeit zu
betreiben diejenigen die ihnen Moschee
Werte vermitteln die mit dem Grundgesetz
nicht vereinbart sind kriegen vor der
Gelder und andere nicht und das ist
absolut dann würde ich gerne einmal wir
haben jetzt zwei Politiker
Bundestagsabgeordnete sitzen einmal CDU
am FDP hat die Politik der vielleicht zu
naiv oder die Parteien also es ist ein
bisschen
wir werden den Islam nicht abschaffen
und wir sollten ihn auch nicht versuchen
abzuschaffen sind eine Milliarde
Menschen es hat gar keinen Sinn zweitens
natürlich nicht aus der Diaspora kommt
die Reform sondern immer aus dem Zentrum
und das können wir nur hoffen da wir
keine Muslime sind und da nicht leben
müssen das andere machen zum Beispiel
iranischen Frauen hoffen wir mal dass
das gut geht ich habe sagen
da sind wir erstmal einer Meinung
aber haben sie auch das Gefühl das
Parallelgesellschaften schon entstehen
in Deutschland
ja also ich finde es ein bisschen sehr
weitgehend parallel aber es gibt Zellen
die ganz klar verfassungsfeindlich sind
wie das islamische Zentrum in Hamburg
die auch kein Geld bekommen dürfen
ist die CDU eigentlich relativ klar wenn
wir gerade vor weiß ich nichts zwei
Monaten im Bundestag entsprechenden
Antrag eingereicht keine Mehrheit
bekommen
es ist also wir sind ein Staat der mit
den einzelnen Gruppen verhandelt wir
verhandeln mit den Gewerkschaften und
Arbeitgebern und dann versuchen wir dann
Kompromiss zu machen ist auch eine große
Stärke von Deutschland und wir mit den
muslimentenlosigkeit also wenn wir
zusammenfassen will ist die Politik der
ratlos beim Problem sozusagen dieses
Phänomen gibt es sonst so in den
deutschen Staaten wir verstehen das
schon als Problem so doof sind jetzt
auch meine Kollegen nicht oder so aber
die Einsatz erlaubten nur Einsatz weil
weil sie gesprochen haben das ist keine
Parallelgesellschaften in Deutschland
gibt ich bin der Meinung gibt es die
sind natürlich sehr begrenzt im
Vergleich zu Frankreich aber ich sage
Ihnen eins das ist keine Gesellschaft
haben wir französische Verhältnisse wenn
wir jetzt nicht anfangen zu agieren wenn
sie nicht anfangen diese Probleme zu
behandeln und da tun wir viel zu wenig
dazu wir wollen was anders sehen wir
haben viele Krisen aber das ist auch
eine Krise die wir behandelt haben das
ist auch eine und natürlich die Recht
der Vertrag mit DITIB ist falsch
wir brauchen mehr islamische Ausbildung
in Deutschland
so den Vertrag was ist das finanziert
von der Türkei die die Tipp machen die
Ausbildung der muss in die Moscheen von
dem Geistlichen die da die Arbeit also
das was wir parallel wir kennen das dann
sein dass wir das unterstützen also weil
wir keine andere Wärme wir haben eben
nur im Kleinen gibt es aber nur in
kleinen Rudimenten alternative
Strukturen die wir dann lieber
finanzieren und der Staat kann immer nur
in Strukturen arbeiten in Deutschland
und nicht einzelne Personen gehen ich
hatte das justizszenator und ähm wir
haben ja mehr deutlich größeren Anteil
Gläubiger Muslime als gläubiger Christen
im
Gefängnissen deswegen haben die auch ein
Rechtsanspruch und Verfassungsanspruch
auf Betreuung der jetzt finden Sie mal
Leute die in den in den in den
Gefängnissen bereit sind
PsychologInnen
Unterschied es gibt einen Unterschied ob
ich dann Muslime da reinbringen die auch
Verfassungs Komfort ist oder ob ich
einen ein politischer islam-aktor der in
Israel sogar teilweise als
terrorfinanzierer gilt und das tut
Berlin und das ist
habe ich das geändert ich nee das ist
nicht gegen viele Schritte von Herrn
Heilmann hier zu sagen wir sind da auch
ein Stück weit ratlos als Politik und
man muss da auf jeden Fall was anders
machen ein paar Sachen sind ja möglich
also
IZH angesprochen hat der Bundestag hat
ja beschlossen dass wir
rausnehmen das ist keine Gelder mehr
kriegen muss ist gestaltet sich wieder
mal schwer in Deutschland wieso alles
schwer ist in Deutschland aber also dass
das Thema haben wir tatsächlich zehn
Jahre ist nicht problematisch seit zwei
Monaten die die Politik reagiert
einem Jahr in der Regierung warum ist 17
Jahre gedauert hat fakt ist der
Bundestag hat jetzt beschlossen
Deutschland Deutschland
ich stehe dazu keine Alternative wir
also wir kümmern uns auch bei der auch
bei den katholischen Kirchen auch bei
den Lehrstunden da reden wir auch mit
ich bin grundsätzlich der Meinung wir
sollten starten Kirche trennen das war
ein anderes Thema aber wir müssen in die
immer Ausbildung einsteigen was er
tatsächlich ein Problem ist wo es nur
wenig Ideen gibt es ist natürlich komoot
mit der christlichen Kirche zu sprechen
da hast du da den Papst der ist sowieso
der Chef von allen und dann hast du eine
klare Struktur wie die EKD von
funktioniert
ganz konkrete
beispielsendung heute an ihn an Sie
stellen also an Dich stellen wenn Du zu
uns erst machen wir auch in der Sendung
du bist ja sehr skeptisch und ein neues
Buch heißt ja auch immer dieses richtig
wiedergeben Operation aller ich muss es
noch lesen wie sieht Deutschland in den
20 Jahren aus hier ist jetzt auch
eingeblendet das Buch aber wie sieht
denn Deutschland in 20 Jahren aus die
Politik ist ratlos aktuell aber wie
würdest du es einschätzen also ich mache
diese Arbeit weil ich auf dem Mist ich
bin auch wenn ich natürlich die Thesen
die
Aktivität sage ich mal anders aussieht
ich glaube das hängt von uns ab also
wenn wir wirklich die Politiker gewinnen
können eine anderen Weg zu gehen einfach
weniger naiv zu sein und konkret auch
nach anderen Strukturen suchen dann bin
ich optimistisch dass wir auch dieses
Problem her werden am Anfang hast du ja
den Vergleich zu Frankreich gezogen
da sind wir also noch nicht es gibt noch
Hoffnung es gibt zehn Jahre da hängt von
uns ab wir mussten jetzt anfangen
dagegen zu steuern in zehn Jahren da
können Sie das Speichern und in 10
Jahren treffen wir uns wenn wir jetzt
nicht handeln haben wir Französisch
Verhältnisse und das macht mir große
Sorgen und es ist möglich absolut
was nehmen sie denn jetzt heute mit hier
bei Operation aller werden sie jetzt
sich da noch mehr engagieren dass das in
unser Land nicht passiert den kann
Innenpolitiker bin auch kein
religionspolitiker wir reden ja von
Fachpolitikern aber ich nehme das als
Anstoß mit meinen Kollegen zu reden ob
er da nicht mehr machen könnte wir gehen
jetzt bestimmt noch mal auf dem Glas
Wein mit Hermann so nach
oben hat man sogar noch mal die
Politiker hier am Tisch davon überzeugen
dass ein sehr wichtiges Thema ist was es
ja auch ist und wir sehen uns morgen
abend wieder bei 8:15 Uhr machen sie es
gut tschüss
[Musik]